now if we're able to think back and
conjure up ancient history we may recall
the night
of may 28th of this past year 2020 when
rioters were demolishing the city of
minneapolis in response to the death of
george floyd
in the middle of that night of chaos
rioters forced their way into the
minneapolis third precinct police
officers then
abandoned the building driving hastily
away in vehicles or retreating on foot
in in full riot gear as the mob hurled
rocks and fireworks at them reportedly
city council members had been begging
the police chief and the mayor to
surrender the building to the riders for
fear that defending it
would only further enrage them we'd want
to make them angry by
defending the police station so the
building was surrendered and eventually
it was
ransacked and torched now this one
incident
one of many similar incidents in
minneapolis and other major cities
across the country over the summer
single-handedly puts to rest any claim
that police used
more violent tactics against blm riders
than they did against the riders at
capitol hill this week
it is very hard to make such a case when
police quite literally handed their
precinct over to the writers
and sat back and watched them burn it to
the ground
let's imagine something what if cops had
decided to stand and fight
defending their building from the
rampaging mob and what if they had used
lethal force to do so and what if in the
ensuing melee
an unarmed black woman had been shot at
near point-blank range in the neck
and killed as she tried to climb through
a broken window into the police station
what if that had happened can there be
any doubt about
the public and political reaction to
such an event is there any chance
that the blm and antifa set in the media
and the democratic party
would ignore the woman's death or
outright defend the officer on the basis
that the black woman
didn't belong there shouldn't have been
climbing in the window
and so deserve to be killed is such a
reaction conceivable
i think we all know it's not this
hypothetical woman
let's pretend her name was say i don't
know ashley babbitt
she would be memorialized with building
size murals
and more rioting would be conducted on
her behalf and athletes like lebron
james would put her name on his jersey
and exhort us to
say her name the outrage over her death
would be
nuclear in proportion and her name would
be famous
in death a martyr for the cause another
canonized saint for social justice
that is how it would have gone with the
hypothetical ashley babbitt and we all
know it
what about the real ashley babbitt
though the real ashley babbitt a white
trump supporter
was killed in real life while
participating in the swarm on the
capitol building on wednesday
according to reports she was unarmed
didn't have a weapon
video of the incident shows that she was
attempting to climb through a broken
window when an officer
shoots her in the neck and kills her
this is inside the capitol building
now we've heard quite a lot about the
killing of unarmed civilians and the
harsh treatment of rioters and here we
have an example of both
she was unarmed she was killed and i
would say shooting someone that's pretty
harsh treatment
but this ashley babbitt has not gotten
the sort of treatment and attention that
our hypothetical ashley babbitt
would have received nor has she gotten
their treatment or attention that
non-hypothetical
violent un violent armed felons
not unarmed but armed felons like jacob
blake have received
after getting shot by police
in this case ashley babbitt has been
mostly ignored by the media and the left
most of the scant attention her death
has attracted has been in the form of
what the left would normally call victim
blaming
perusing google this morning i could not
find a single headline
a single one in any major publication
that identified her as an
unarmed woman in the headline which is
strange because usually
unarmed is the first thing they tell us
in these kinds of situations
the next thing they tell us is the race
of the person
usually most of the headlines that i've
seen about this shooting
are like this one from nbc news that
says woman killed in capital
was trump supporter who embraced
conspiracy theories
now the article goes on in the great
detail um
telling us about all the sins the dead
woman committed on social media for
example
quoting from the article it says using
the handle common ash
sense babbitt's twitter account was
almost singularly focused on radical
conservative topics and conspiracy
theories
among other fringe beliefs she tweeted
about pizzagate a viral disinformation
campaign that falsely alleged a child
abuse ring was
being operated by democrats from a
washington pizza restaurant
babbitt was a loyal fox news watcher
according to thousands of tweets to fox
news host but she also engaged on social
media with the conspiracy news internet
news site
uh infowars in 2020 babbitt began to
tweet with q anon accounts and used q
anon hashtags q anon conspiracy theories
subscribe to a false belief that
high profile democrats and hollywood
celebrities are ritually sacrificing
children that trump is fighting to stop
it
two announced followers have allegedly
committed real-world violent crimes
including murder
and the fbi labeled it a potential
domestic terror threat in 2019
unquote so those now
you know again normally somebody's
killed by police we're told that
um details about their life are
irrelevant
the fact that george floyd forced his
way into a woman's house
and put a gun to her stomach that's not
relevant we can't talk about that
but the fact that ashley babbitt tweeted
some kooky conspiracy
theories that's relevant
many more details are provided about
babbitt's tweeting habits
as for information on the shooting
itself
almost nothing is provided at all
in fact i could find only one mention of
the fact that she was unarmed in any
mainstream publication forget about just
the headline
okay it's not in any headline but is it
even in the article
i found one article one the washington
post
in the last sentence of the third
paragraph of its article on the shooting
quotes two law enforcement officials who
confirm that she was unarmed
now could the shooting still be
justified babbitt was
where she should not have been doing
something that she should not have been
doing
that's clear but if that alone justifies
deadly force then police would have
license to kill many people at many of
the riots that have broken out around
the country
it's hard to see how the officer who
pulled the trigger could have reasonably
viewed babbitt
as a lethal threat to himself or anyone
else she's a small
unarmed woman climbing through a window
could they not have pushed her back
could they not have taken her to the
ground and cuffed her
video shows and this is really important
there was a whole line of armed heavily
armed law enforcement officers
coming up the steps directly behind her
i mean they were a few feet
from her when she was killed could none
of them have simply grabbed her and
pulled her away
or are the reports wrong did ashley
babbitt actually have a weapon
or did the officer think she had one i
doubt it based on the video footage
but i don't know because the media isn't
bothering to ask
did he fire because she was wearing a
backpack and he thought there might be
explosives in it again that seems
dubious since lots of people were
wearing backpacks and they didn't kill
anybody else
and lots of people at other riots wear
bags and that's never a justification to
shoot any of them
again it's hard again it's hard to know
because the media isn't bothering to
look for answers
nobody is demanding accountability
do we even know the name of the officer
who pulled the trigger has he been put
on administrative leave while
the investigation is underway as is
usually par for the course in these
situations
there appears to be little interest in
these questions the people who have
again spent years panicking over police
shootings especially police shootings of
unarmed people
are happy to simply let this one slide
just let it go we won't even ask about
it
this is not what would happen if ashley
babbitt
had a different political affiliation
and a different skin color
and that is not a double standard that
we should simply accept
and say well that's just the way it goes
the media only cares and reports
if um you know you're on the left and
especially if you're not white
i don't think we should just accept that
one thing is clear the left has poured
into the streets to protest and riot
over police shootings that were easily
more justified than this
starting with michael brown who was who
was uh
killed while in the process of
assaulting a police officer and trying
to take his gun
there's no rational argument that would
make brown's killing wrong
but babbitt's killing right
the double standard and the apparent
incoherence here is only confusing until
you realize
that the movement against police
brutality actually has nothing at all to
do with police brutality and never did
the deaths of men like brown were simply
excuses
they provided cover a forum they were a
trojan horse
tragedies used to justify anarchy and to
enact
the left's radical cultural agenda if
the concern was really over brutality
then these people would at least be
asking questions about ashley babbitt's
killing
they would at least be demanding some
answers
they would at least care but they don't
because they're frauds and always have
been
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated